hey jalen uh
jalen uh the fact that you got with
everything that's been going on in the
outside world
you've been in the bubble for over two
months can you talk about what happened
in the locker room afterwards
nothing really just you know a lot of
emotions
just flying around obviously i feel like
we could have won
you know should have won or and we
didn't
so just a lot of emotions flying around
that's it
next question is from abby chin
i'm on boats right now uh guys there
were reports of yelling in the locker
rooms and things being throwed marcus
obviously exited um emotional can you
just kind of speak to that scene or
describe what it was like
you know he plays with passion he's full
of fire
and that's what i love about it most to
be honest
you know he has that desire and that
will we need him
to continue to have that you know it's
ups and downs
with families all the time but you know
we embrace each other for who we are and
who marcus is i love him for it
so we got to get ready to come back take
that same fire
and uh add it to game three
chris ryan yeah jalen just shoot your
thoughts on that shot to tie it with
15.1 seconds to go your thoughts when it
you know left your hand and also
why you feel that you guys find
yourselves in this in this hole in the
series
i thought it was a good shot all the
time
sounded a little bit long that was it
what was the second question
next question jalen is from andres lopez
thank you uh jalen you guys are 2-0 in a
conference final
from a more psychological standpoint how
do you guys remain locked in on this
series that is
far from over yet exactly what you just
said
um we in the conference finals that's
all we need to
to hear to be locked in that's all it
takes you know
both in both games we had moments where
we had lapses and
that team over there is together for 48
minutes and we got to be together
48 minutes and match that i think that
we've yet to do that
i think we're capable i think we need
every piece every everybody to be all in
and
and to continue to bring that energy is
what we're going to need but
i think this series is far from over um
i'm ready for game three i'm ready to
come out because
you know that's what it's all about back
against the wall ups downs and
fight regardless
back back to bob tron
thanks jeff uh obviously you were ahead
had that big lead in the first half but
then you regrouped after they made their
run
down the stretch in the fourth quarter
did you guys maybe hit the wall
with three minutes to go looked like you
were
getting a little tired at that point was
that at all a factor
no i think yeah at this point you know
physical fatigue becomes less and less
it's more mental
you know so we just got to be sound
execute and stay together that's it
we feel confident about our abilities we
feel confident about the game plan
we just haven't executed it to the
extent that we know we can
two games that we came up short um
towards the end of the game and
we're looking forward to game three got
to come out we got to find a way to win
jeff please remember question jalen is
from chris ryan no jeff we have
questions in the room as well here
okay so you want to take that one on
zoom and then we'll do the three in the
room
brian thanks
chris john can you hear me yeah okay
um just the biggest reasons why you feel
that you're down
you know two at this point you guys
discuss complacency after
game one what are the biggest reasons in
your view that you're down in this area
is the way you are
um we just haven't played a full 48
minutes of being locked in
and executing the game plan for like
maybe about 75 percent
we play really well and it's always one
quarter or one
sequence of events where we have lapses
and uh against this team we can't have
those
you know if we take that away
question in person jalen from gary
there's a washburn of stuff going on
there is everything
now are you gonna have to spend tomorrow
or guys about to meet again later
tomorrow
and come together again or is it or did
y'all
make up i think everything is understood
um we're gonna have a meeting tomorrow
regardless just to watch the film and
over the game playing with coach
but you know at the end of the day you
know motion is gonna fly
obviously we wanted to win this game and
we did but this series is far from over
and then we got to get ready for game
three you know that's how it goes you
know with families as ups and downs
there's fighters emotions
but that's exactly what we are family
you know we're going
to hold each other accountable and we
got to do what it takes to come out and
execute
and scan did you say that what happened
it was needed i think so i think it's a
beauty to it
uh or whatever you know
a lot of people are passionate and
emotional and i'm one of those people so
um i recognize it as that i recognize it
as emotions passion i don't recognize it
there's nothing else
um the media might see it or or whatever
that's all it is is passion
just being you know expressed so we got
to express that same passion
next game for 48 minutes period
final question jalen from michael
rosenberg in person please thank you
when you talk about lapses and 75 of the
game you play well
do you think this is a problem before
this series as well
uh i don't think it's a problem i think
it's just you know
i think it's growth that's taking place
i mean we've been challenged
you know throughout this playoffs you
know multiple times to
to continue to grow we got a young group
we got a group that
you know is you know new to playoff
experience for the most part
especially you know playing together so
i don't think it's a problem it's just
things that we have to improve on
you know what i mean that we and that we
have in certain moments and we haven't
in certain moments so um it's a great
opportunity to show growth
thank you very much jalen
did you and brad talk about playing
fewer minutes you you played about 34
minutes in this one didn't get into the
fourth quarter until about eight minutes
to go
no we had we did it well
just happened that way
abby chin
oh i'm on both right now uh guys there
were reports of
yelling in the locker rooms and things
being thrown marcus obviously exited
um emotional can you just kind of speak
to that scene or describe
what it was like it was nothing
it was nothing tim bonten
tim bontes yeah what happened in the
third quarter
uh
man they they all play this
they all play this you know it's you
know really
unacceptable on our behalf and it was
it was just a really bad quarter for us
you know we um
we didn't we didn't continue to do the
things that
you know we we did to you know get us up
and get us that lead
you know i think we got kind of
comfortable and those guys they took
great advantage of it they played hard
they played really hard they played a
lot harder than i said
they wanted it when you guys got back up
by five late in the fourth quarter they
went on another big run and turned the
game around what
what happened there and and how do you
guys have a third
quarter like that and that end of the
game after the way the fourth quarter
went in game one
uh
i don't know you know um we fought our
way back
but you know just just a lot of mistakes
man you know we
make you know too many minor mistakes
out there that really
don't hurt us you know we gotta we gotta
clean that up
you know in order to to beat these guys
adam hillsbot
with things getting kind of emotional
after the game what do you kind of have
to do
as a leader to make sure this doesn't
things don't go the wrong way and you
kind of keep everyone together and bring
everyone together it won't
and ain't nothing nothing happened in
the locker room i don't know what you're
talking about to be honest
you know we'll be fine it'll be fun
brian rob
kemp but their uh zone defense seemed to
give you guys a lot of issues there in
the second half um
what do you guys need to just you know
do better against that to
get better looks oh we're gonna watch
the film we're gonna watch the film um
but you know we gotta we gotta find the
way that's that's really it
you know we gotta you know get into the
lane um
and just make plays
jared weiss there were a bunch of plays
where
you had three guys under the rim on
defense and the ball would go up for a
rebound and you guys would be staring at
each other and then
someone from miami would fly in to get
the rebound how do you guys have to
communicate better to just make sure you
get those defensive rebounds and prevent
those huge chances
no that's that's all it is that's all i
know so they do a great job at you know
flying in
obviously i do a better job at no
getting on their bodies
um you know prevent those guys from
from getting in the lane you know when
the ball goes in the air but we got to
hit some bodies
all right we'll wrap it up right there
thank you appreciate it
jayson tatum will be next he'll be our
final player available on this card this
evening
all right jason tatum will be up
momentarily
all right questions for jason
start with chris ryan
and jason there's been reports about
what happened in in the locker room
tonight and marcus becoming emotional
what were your takeaways from
from that and is all good coming out of
it
um i don't know who said that
we owe it too i mean we just
i mean we're frustrated but uh i mean
that's team sports
we're not supposed to be happy to be
down on o2 but
nothing out the ordinary just talking
about the game
it's cool gotta get ready for the next
one tim bontemps
jason what happened in the third quarter
uh they all played us that's uh
long story short layout playlist
and then down the stretch you guys got
back up five they're going to take a
17-6 run to close the game
was it a similar thing there and how do
you guys have that happen after
the way the fourth quarter went in game
one yeah that's tough
uh offensive rebounds
some key turnovers miscommunication they
get some big shots
uh mean
a lot of things went wrong
but i get ready for the next
adam himmelsbach jason you only
attempted two three-pointers what are
the challenges i guess in finding looks
against their zone and what do you have
to do to kind of free yourself up to
to get more opportunities next game from
beyond the arc
um i think just being ready to shoot
obviously um
being just shoot over the finish any day
late i get
i think i turn a couple of them down
which i shouldn't do
so uh that's on me question in person
gary washburn
what happened after the game was that
necessary did you get that out
what happened after the game
um i mean what happened after the game
what happens in the locker room we gotta
stay in the locker room
uh it's not supposed to come out here
and talk about
you know what we talk about as a team
after a win or a loss
uh that's why we're going to locker room
and talk to each other but
whether we win we lose so i mean that's
that's that
what happens tomorrow either it seems
like you could go
up respond to go down and
kind of get in what what do you guys how
do y'all approach tomorrow
um i figured some things out uh
two times now we've had a couple
double-digit leads and
you know we've let go the ropes so we
gotta figure out you know why that keeps
happening
um and just be prepared to win the next
one you know we're not looking at we got
to win four
out of five or how many we got left
um just win the next one just take one
game at a time
abby chin
jason a lot of talk about their zone
defense
we've seen you guys break down the zone
we know that you know what to do
why is that scheme giving you so much
trouble
uh i wish i knew i mean i gotta look at
the film
um but you gotta have better spacing i
think
a lot of times we just weren't in the
right spots
and whether against man or zone um
you know that's not gonna help y'all we
gotta have the right spacing
uh in order to create um good movement
um create a good shot i mean it's
basically messed up
against a good team good defensive team
uh stuff
final couple of questions jared weiss
you mentioned the offensive rebounds
that they were getting there were fewer
i mean you've been dominating the class
in the fourth quarters lately but there
were a few plays
in this game where you were you and a
teammate were kind of looking at each
other and didn't go up
for the ball while miami went up for the
ball of fun
guy what are the communication
breakdowns there how come it's not
everybody going up for the ball the way
it usually is
yeah i mean that's not me um you know i
didn't rebound nearly as good
as uh you know i normally have been
and uh you know you can't expect other
people to get it you just gotta go up
there and get it
but tip it to somebody um so yeah
rebounding that was
i i gotta take ownership on that uh
you know we i gotta rebound way better
than i did tonight
final question for jason brian rob
um jason you you guys have seen a lot of
zone obviously against toronto and in
this series what is
one of the challenges miami presents
with you know just their length and
athletizing that and that's you know
different from
what you guys have seen before um
similar to run on me they're great great
team
great defensively um you know they long
they help so like i said earlier we just
gotta
we gotta be in the right spots whatever
we running
um spacing is key on offense
and tonight i don't think we did a great
job of that i think that was a parent
watching the game
fixable so uh get ready for the next one
take one game